make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are picking back up again
with x-men Fantastic Four number two and
I love the first one right the idea of
like Franklin Richards you know wanting
to join the x-men and for those of you
guys who didn't see our first video
you'll find the link to it down in the
description a lot of you guys have asked
about that a lot of you guys have kind
of expressed frustration insofar as
we're doing like multiple part videos
and then we don't link the previous
video in the description so we're gonna
start doing that so so Jacob if you're
editing this or Gordon if you're editing
this from now on put the link to the
previous video in a series at the top of
the description so that people can go
see it because we don't want folks to be
lost but in the first video we have
basically talked about how you had the
x-men showing up on the doorstep of the
Fantastic Four and basically putting
forward this idea that Franklin Richards
is a mutant and as such he belongs in
krakoa
now an important thing to understand
here is the x-men we're not going to
take Franklin against his will right
it's one of these things worked when it
comes to krakoa it's something just an
offer that's there right the x-men
aren't gonna show up on your doorstep
through a black bag over your head and
then drag you to her Cola it's simply an
option that's there now most mutants
have taken advantage of it right because
it's a safe haven there among their own
kind they can kind of experience and
engage and enjoy their own culture but
also because there's safety in numbers
right not to mention there's some pretty
heavy hitters on cocoa apocalypse
magneto different things like that you
know Exodus especially Exodus is
ridiculously overpowered people are
sleeping on how powerful Exodus is and I
feel like during Hickman's run on x-men
you're gonna see just how powerful
Exodus can be because he is he is a hoss
it's isn't it's nuts like it's it's
crazy how powerful like that that's what
everything and telekinesis man that guy
is nuts
but regardless you know it's one of the
offers is basically just there and so
when the X minutes shown up on the
Fantastic Four's doorstep and said hey
look we want Franklin to come join us on
krakoa immediately the Fantastic Four
hit the roof and they were like no I won
because they were concerned parents and
they didn't want their kid just
gallivanting off with the x-men but -
because one of the things to remember is
that when it comes to the x-men and
krakoa while the x-men are doing this
you know and really the mutant
population is doing this as a means to
kind of give themself a safe haven
they're also remaining a very
cloak-and-dagger right very ambiguous to
the world and so the Fantastic Four
don't really even know what's going on
there's a lot of questions that were
never really answered and of course mama
Bayer Susan storm started freaking out
and so during that whole that whole
conflict essentially Kitty Pryde
I kind of talked to Franklin and said
hey like are you interested in this kind
of thing and then ultimately Franklin
ended up just kind of taking off and
then in turn basically sneaking aboard
kitty pryde ship with the Marauders and
where he was essentially discovered by
by dr. doom right and so what this does
is it picks up with the kind of a
conversation that takes place afterwards
this idea that you have Cyclops and you
have the x-men who we're all kind of
talking to you the Fantastic Four and
the fan has like forward kind of looking
at them and saying hey look we don't
know where our kid is but you're the
reason why he took off and and so on and
so forth but it's one of these things
where they're kind of trying to talk
reason to the team right trying to be
reasonable here and say hey look here's
what's really going on when it comes to
the bigger picture but Susan storm
doesn't want to listen and in this kind
of anger in this this moment of reaction
she lashes out and so where Cyclops
turns back to Magneto and says it's
gonna be a problem and the reason why is
because again Susan storm is wildly
powerful she's one of the most
underrated characters in Marvel Comics
in terms of the power she possesses
right being able to create force fields
being able to be invisible you know you
can't hit what you can't see and if
Susan storm shows up on your doorstep
and you can't see that she's there and
then she opens a force field inside your
head and makes it explode or decides to
make you suffocate inside of a force
field there's not much you're gonna be
able to do to stop her right it's gonna
take a super high-level telepath in
order to basically bring her down right
so in a lot of ways she's kind of the
most dangerous member of the Fantastic
Four outside of like Franklin Richards
and so what this does is it kind of
turns the discussion on its head where
you have Reed coming in and saying look
they're a nation we can't necessarily
just go in there and take our son back
we would essentially be waging war that
kind of a thing everybody really kind of
points to Reed and says but you're the
one that ran him off in the first place
right you're the one that put that
inhibitor on him they basically took
away the ability for cacoa to recognize
him as a mutant you're the one that
basically made the choice for him and
saying you're never gonna be able to go
over koa because you cannot pass through
the gates
it was Reed's desire as a parent to keep
his son safe but he also took away his
sons ability to choose and that
ultimately is what led to Franklin
Richards leaving and so what we end up
doing is picking back up with Kitty
Pryde and company because as we saw when
dr. doom showed up at the end of the
last video it was what in the world's
gonna happen and when they wake up
they're really all kind of brought there
as individuals who were there for the
purpose of dr. doom not really to
conquer but to kind of talk to right
it's really more of like a meeting of
friends is almost kind of how it comes
across now it is intriguing that dr.
doom chose to knock everybody out and
then drag them to this secret island but
the reason why that was done is because
the island is secret no one's supposed
to know about it right it's called doom
island and what he did here is he
basically created a
refuge for himself this hidden away from
the world right so it's not picked up on
any form of radar or sonar and it's
physically invisible to the human eye
but it's kind of a cool thing because
what he says here is his whole goal the
reason why he's here is not to conquer
mutants it's not to somehow force the
hand on the mutant population or to
invade piccola or anything like that
it's because his goal is to basically
wake up the powers of Franklin Richards
to wake his powers up to the point where
is that their full potential now again
in the last video what we saw was that
Franklin's powers were essentially
weakening right he was losing his powers
and the idea was that he had a kind of
connection to the god power right this
idea that all these super powerful
mutants or harvests looked at basically
get their abilities from quote-unquote
the god power and Franklin Richards get
so it gets all his abilities from that
directly but he seems to have lost that
connection at least according to the
speculation of Reed Richards and so
restoring that connection will route
will restore his powers dr. where they
were but the conversation here from dr.
doom seems to be to amplify his
abilities right to make him more
powerful than he was before his power
started dropping off and so what you end
up doing is jumping over to the x-men
where they kind of started having this
conversation right they're talking about
things like should we either go to where
we can locate Kitty Pryde since they've
picked up on her location at least
Xavier has should we go there to where
she is or should we prepare for an
attack from the Fantastic Four because
the belief of the Fantastic Four not
knowing that dr. doom has Franklin in
all of them is that the x-men are in
possession of Franklin the Franklin was
either taken by the x-men or went there
willingly but regardless their goal is
to get their son back and so ultimately
this smartest move here is to prepare
for a conflict from the Fantastic Four
right to prepare for that to defend
against that and then if things pop off
to in turn try to overcome that battle
and then go find Franklin but to
basically defend their home territory
first and this is when things get cool
because what you end up having here is
this kind of conversation between Emma
Frost magneto Cyclops and Nightcrawler
and Nightcrawler really says well here's
the thing guys like you can plan all you
want to but there's no planning for the
mind of Reed Richards right he can do
anything he wants to chances are he's
considered a possibility like this
before bearing in mind of the x-men and
the Fantastic Four have fought in the
past so that would lead Reed Richards to
kind of create safety measures for a
situation like this where he had to
fight the x-men again or he could just
think on the spot and because he's so
highly intelligent he'd be able to come
up with any number of things almost
instantaneously and nest where
Nightcrawler says and that's the danger
of it all because given the mind of Reed
Richards and the power of Susan storm
The Invisible Woman
they could have here virtually anywhere
and then boom out of nowhere they're
just there
the Fantastic Four been there the whole
time that's the crazy thing about it is
like the Invisible Woman kept them
invisible and they just showed up on the
doorstep of the x-men and it's like how
could you not know this but that's the
power right that's the power of the
Fantastic Four because what they done is
they had put on helmets that it
basically blocked telepathic detection
right so none of the telepaths knew they
were there no one knew they were there
and they just showed up here Susan storm
made them invisible and then sunny
they're launching an attack now right
off the bat Cyclops makes the smart move
and takes out Susan storm when he looks
at that and says okay she's a linchpin
behind which their entire attack centers
take her out and everything else
crumbles and that's exactly what happens
the Susan storm is knocked out and the
now is just Reed Richards Ben Grimm and
Johnny Storm facing off against the
x-men and despite how powerful they are
the defensive abilities best Susan storm
offers the ability to create force
fields the ability to render members of
her team and herself invisible as
something that's just not easily
overcome with Susan storm out of the
equation now the rest of the Fantastic
Four are really just kind of on the
fence right doing the best they can to
fend off against these guys and really
you kind of have guys like like
Nightcrawler jumping in you've got
Cyclops jumping in that kind of thing
and they're able to overcome each one of
them quite readily Reed Richards is of
course trying to wake up Susan storm and
then that's when it really dawns on him
the helmet the helmet is the key right
the helmets that's the key to waking
Susan storm up and so what he does is he
pops the helmet of Susan storm Emma
Frost chimes in says someone together
got the helmet of Susan storm off not
realizing what's going on and then her
psychic attack wakes up Susan storm and
then the helmet slammed back on again
sue those storms back up and they're
back to the races this is the ingenuity
and the intelligence of Reed Richards
and is awesome the chip sidarsky rode
him like this it's a genius thought
process and that's what Nightcrawler was
talking about when he was referencing
the intelligence of read and how capable
he is right and so of course Susan storm
does exactly what we thought she would
do which is create a force field and the
team basically gets out of there and
they travel to the location of where
Kitty Pryde is supposed to be with the
rest of the x-men following suit and so
following that you pick up with Kitty
Pryde and the Marauders really kind of
coming to this recollection of what's
likely going to happen here if Franklin
Raiders is here they deduce the entire
situation the x-men are basically going
to try to locate Franklin Richards
they're gonna realize Kitty Pryde is
here they're gonna locate Kitty pry
they're gonna come to the island the
Fantastic Four are going to
leave the x-men have Franklin Richards
are gonna end up in a conflict with the
x-men and then learn the location of
where Franklin Richards really is or at
least where Kitty Pryde was who is the
last person seen with Franklin and
they're gonna end up in this location
right so everybody's gonna show up on
the doorstep of dr. Doom's Citadel and
this is when things get cool because
what Doctor Doom basically says is when
the questions asked what are we gonna do
like are you prepared for some kind of
conflict like this dr. doom says yes dr.
doom is always prepared and what we end
up finding out is that doom is basically
creating sentinels he's been creating
these dr. doom like these doom bots
enormous sentinels the difference here
is that when humanity created sentinels
they created them using whatever
technology and whatever knowledge
humanity had dr. doom is smarter than
all of them what you're talking about is
Doctor Doom one of the smartest people
in the entirety of the Marvel Universe
with all kinds of different resources at
his disposal to say nothing of his
technology and magical abilities
creating sentinels I would wager these
guys would decimate the x-men though
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
to come this explain to make sure you
guys with the sub button to become part
of the Rob core if you guys enjoy this
video make sure you drop a like and I
will catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Applause]